we have something we don't get to test
very often we have the Oppo finn3 a
foldable phone equipped with a large
camera moner at the back that has hassle
blood lenses and Sony sensors and on the
inside there is a near unnoticeable
crease we're going to play hongkai
starel genin impact Call of Duty mobile
which will be playing with a spiffy
backbone controller and lastly pubg
mobile the Oppo 593 is running the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 chip it's GPU and
adreno 740 16 gigs of RAM and we've got
512 gigs of storage with it being a
foldable phone it runs two displays the
external screen is a 6.3 in while the
internal when unfolded is a 7.8 in
screen both are AMOLED screens with ltpo
that run at 120 HZ so with that let's do
a baseline unfold it since the games are
going to be compl unfolded anyway with
our temperature gun so let's check it
out from here at the back
20.5 very steady I mean the leather is
kind of helping up the camera module
does go up a little bit or actually does
go down because it's glass
and let's check this other screen here
26.8 nothing too fancy nothing to
alarming of course we just start it and
at the front let's just turn the screen
on all right big swipes 27 29 nothing
really pushing 30 so oh okay yep now
it's pushing 30 by a little but that's
okay it's still very comfortable to hold
all right so with that let's get into to
our first game H stel all right so we do
have a FPS GPU and CPU counter so
running currently it's at 30 FPS so
let's just do that and let's increase
the volume so we do have different
battery modes here we got balance low
power and pro gamer mode which obviously
will boost up that heat sick and
honestly most of you will be on the go
we just be playing on balanced mode to
see how much better you can save while
pushing the game to its limits and in
order to push those limits we're going
to be changing up the settings all right
now that we're in settings we're going
to go to very high very high 60
FPS and yep everything is turned on no
fairy drops or anything I mean this
thing is running a Snap Dragon H and two
and adrenal 740 so I wouldn't be
expecting that many hiccups from this
set of chips and see you how on looks
great but more importantly kka
yes right kka is looking pretty good and
so far switching characters I think we
are doing pretty good right very
seamless no frite jobs whatsoever so
with that let's just get into the
simulated Universe the speakers are on
the sides of the phone on both sides so
as you can see it's muffling up things
when I hold it like this so do keep that
in mind again headphones are always the
best way for things so I'm going to be
kind of blasting this a little bit more
I will say that the camera module does
get away a little bit bit but honestly
this isn't the largest camera Modo I've
seen so it's still not too bad from what
I'm used to and also because of the way
the screen is light when it's unfolded
you're going to get these black bars
here so they'll be let boxing come on I
want to try something
out very fun let me end your misery all
right let's do a quick Al to see how
things
work the plays all right let's see how
this thing handles all these flaming
L let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
frostar all right very smooth animations
no issues whatsoever so we're doing
pretty
good let's speed things
up
all will be
revealed lar
flame even with set up everything rning
very smoly let
see more
shot all right there we go
nice
Elite we need a strategy no we do
not the moon shines
truth quite a
bit with everything you got actually I
don't need her but um misplay this bit
but so good I'll free you from your
disappear among the Sea of butterflies
illusions of the past
blaz all will be
revealed lunar
Flame
re
this all right keep
going L on
H okay because I don't want to T A game
longer than I should we already pass the
40 minute Mark for this game which is
still quite a bit that's about an entire
match of pubg or Call of Duty Dr all
right let's check Final
temperatures and on the front
37.8 85.2
31 nothing too crazy here okay it's 41
around here but that's understandable
because that's where the chip is at
especially in the middle this is the
where the creep is at right here but
besides that the rest of the phone is
still very comfortable to hold and
because the chip is in the middle and
you're holding another part of the
screen on the top here most of it is
kind of from like cold to hot so it's
not super uncomfortable though I will
say this camera module will probably get
in the way so in all the curve that we
will be playing with the backbone but
again the backbone only supports certain
gam so just be mindful of
that
and all right nothing too crazy with the
highest just being around this area but
even then this phone is it's quite sick
so besides the leather boxing it did
take quite a bit it took a long time for
the phone to really start breaking down
if I can say that because the FPS has
been quite constant between like 55 to
60 throughout most of the play through
or even at the most 50 it might dip
lower than that but it won't go drastic
like 26 23 like we saw earlier on but
besides that the phone is handling H
stario pretty well I can't wait to see
why it runs like with G impact which
we'll be getting into right now and also
one more thing to note we started this
game and also one one thing to note we
started this game test at 100% we are
currently 82% so with that let's get
into genit impact all right so we are
hot off the heels of honai Star had to
let the camera as a bit it was
overheating but currently we at 81%
battery and let's check temperatures
they flat on the ground well not really
flat but yes I believe everything has
gone down quite a bit yeah we're almost
at the same base temperatures as when we
first checked them out so doing pretty
good Oppo damn right let's check the
back all right
29.2 and yeah pretty much uniform around
here except getting to the chip now as
you can see it's kind of rising up now
29.8 30 and on camera modum nothing
much okay doing pretty good another
thing to note the game booster does
automatically adjust the phone and
optimizes it for gaming so that's
something to keep in mind except for
this little counter here you will need
to activate it on your own all right now
the we engageing impact we can see that
the UI is pretty much sorted out for
foldable phones everything is around
here and your thumb has easy placements
unless un you have huge hands like mine
it'll be slightly harder to navigate but
on that it's pretty much manageable but
let's check settings real quick all
right so in settings everything set to
the highest we at 60 FPS and other than
that I think we are pretty much good to
go all right now look it's looking
really good and so far even if I push
the camera like that there are no frame
rate drops whatsoever let me just enable
that frame rate counter again that FPS
counter all right
aaka very much seamless all right very
seamless okay sick and with that let's
run through
Inazuma all right it is turning to
evening here things are rendering in
very nicely let's keep
moving very very slight F chops okay
it's it's around 40 30 right now again
the phone isn't out yet so genin
obviously isn't optimized for the opo F
and 3
so you will see it dip down below 50
quite a bit we don't talking about 60
we're talking about 50 as you can see
and let's uh just jump down
41 so with that in mind let's go into
some exploration and
[Music]
[Applause]
combat all right so far combat is
looking pretty good pretty D promising
it's just that as you can see I'm kind
of pushing up here quite a bit because
of how the phone is like especially with
the cam module right here at the bottom
all right so that's done if I can get
this right we'll be able to land right
on top of them oh let's get the Archer
first
though all
right okay Archer is down come on move
out okay I'm kind of glitched in right
now oh my Lord this is not how I
expected it to go but it is going the
way it is because um right great great
stuff Frozen you dying you're dying you
dying come on you're dying you
dying all right and everyone is down uh
with that let's get into the final bit I
almost call it the simulator Universe
let's go to the abyss the spiral
Abyss all right first chamber
time oh very
nice all right let's keep whacking him
come on and also registration isn't that
great
so yeah I mean it's it's probably
because I have such huge hands that's
the only reason I can't think of right
now very
nice come
on
y all right one down
come on dpsm come on come on come on
there we go all right we are done so
with that let's check Final
temperatures all right currently
2833 honestly it it didn't feel that hot
nothing kind of went off it's still
giving off the same performance honkai
star so I'm pretty surprised even I'm
pretty surprised even though this one
hasn't been released yet that it is
somewhat working is can't be as B other
phones but it can't be as other phones
pre-launched but this phone is working
on pretty well honestly it's just a
Snapdragon and adrenal faulty combo
undefeated still around this area it's
still oh it's not even at 40 all right
so with that very interesting and also
we're at 75% battery down from 81 so I
think wow it's doing pretty good with
genin a lot better than I expected
though so with that let's get into Call
of Duty mobile with the backbone all
right so now that we are off gin impact
let's check temperatures real quick
we're currently at
72% of course have to let the camera
cool down a little bit and of course the
phone as well
80 oh why is it why is it in Fahrenheit
back to Celsius because we don't use the
imperial system here uh
28.6 uh 29.7 30 all right not too bad
again 9
29.7 very much uniform around the area
here and
28 and yeah I think we're good so with
that let's attach the backbone which I'm
going need to zoom out a bit for we only
have one USBC slot and that's where the
module is at and the thing about the
backbone is it has a backbone so that
thing kind of clashes so let's just let
me just show you all right so you going
to put this thing in here kind of
stretch it out right and it obviously
just takes the the top half and once you
put it in it's not exactly stable
because of how the back is like just
look at that
it's a bit it's not exactly ideal but
this is what we're working with and yeah
with that let's just get
into Call of Duty now that we're in Call
of Duty mobile um obviously because the
phone can't exactly detect that it's a
backbone I to select it manually so
let's get into settings and check
settings real quick uh we're going to go
with very high graphic quality and Max
frame rate you're going to be playing a
round of Battle Royale so let's just get
into a match all right very very smooth
and the game looks really good let me
just zoom in on that
action going try to keep it in this for
as long as I can and finally I'm in a
squad I'm not playing alone okay no no
I'm not jump Master
still okay let's just go wherever he's
going but so far so good we're keeping
it at a steady 60 to 59 FPS or the other
way around and it's looking to be pretty
good I mean honestly dud we are dudes
and do that and do we are running in Jal
Zone faulty with a snap Dron agent 2 on
Call of Duty mobile so honestly honestly
not one of the most intensive
games but you know what we
ball got enemies on here
oh what the hell you guys saw that right
all right let one
down oh I don't think I'll be using the
m6 for long but there's someone behind
me I
believe
[Music]
oh
nope okay I just need to get proper use
to the controls the revive
will very nice quite a bit of stff St oh
yes we're going to go AK I don't care
we're going
AK oh
okay I not hitting anyone with the
sniper rifle oh my gosh okay there will
be nothing in this game that would
hinder the performance of oh there you
are oh my God okay great oh oh that's
terrible okay there we
go four more people to go down let's
just hunt oh on my
left all right three more peeps I think
we got some more people on that side
Green's over here oh there you
are there we go what a way to end the
game I finally get a good kill oh my God
okay so honestly very far in the
backbone as usual this thing will not
let you down whatsoever just need to
tune the settings to your likeing for
other than that when it comes of
temperature and everything I mean
honestly even though the backbone is on
there's still a good amount it's not
covering the entire phone right it's
just covering the phone partially and
even then this little module does get in
the way so I don't think I can count a
lot on
the um I I don't think overheat or
anything cuz honestly you know what
there's still enough ventilation going
through so with that let's just check
temperatures okay so I've taken a
backbone okay so I've taken a backbone
off we are currently at 65% okay these
games do take up quite a bit from on the
phone so with that let's check
temperatures real quick especially
hongkai star that like what 20ish per
29% so with that let's check
temperatures and 28.9 honestly not
expecting much Call of Duty Mobile isn't
the most taxing game on our list so is
pubg mobile but people want to see how
the games perform on them and that's why
they're in there okay so let's check the
back and the back right now is 28°
28.7 29 oh okay no complaints
very very good temperatures coming out
of this phone for Call of Duty mobile
and pubg very good temperatures coming
out
okay let's check the back real okay
let's check the back now and 27 27 28 on
the chip air on 29 okay again not the
most tax in game and we're getting the
numbers that we kind of want so with
that let's get into our final game pubg
mobile before we get into pubg mobile
let's get into temperature checks we are
currently we at 64% battery and let's
just check temperatures in the
front 27.3 27.7
27.3 yeah another notes at the crease
you know what can't see anything that's
that's pretty cool all right so 28 27
pretty good numbers and let's check the
back really
quickly all right 28 let's check the Le
side first where the chips are at 28 28
28 all very good numbers coming out the
module 26 all right as expected and
let's check the other side looking
pretty good it is dissipating he pretty
well all right handing thermal is pretty
good so with that let's get into pubg
Mobile all right now that we're in pubg
mobile let's check settings real quick
we are at smooth graphics and 90 FPS
general settings four times an eling and
pretty much everything is all right so
with that let's just get into a match
also I will say that I already have
customized the buttons to fit my play
style and comfort levels been playing
pubg mobile but here is pubg Mobile in
all its Glory this is how it looks like
it kind of feels like the fov is kind of
pushed up quite a bit I mean obviously
there's no leather boxing so let's see
how it looks like in first person if I
can get it
there plus% looks okay still kind of bit
weired out by the fov but other than
that I think looks pretty much fine
but it's running very smoothly let's
just get that system settings real quick
out so I can check our FPS and let's see
system State this all right 89 88 so we
are running this at 90
FPS and let's just get into the game
no all right things are looking pretty
good I got my streamers up and I don't
think they'll probably be go behind us
so let's just get the Pinki real
quick going to be in Fr of their wave
pattern right about now so I'll be
heading towards that side of town where
marer is
at and so far no huge frame rate drops
we're still playing around the 85 to 90
region so things are looking pretty
good I don't know why green is out but
you know what never
mind his problem not mine
all
right H okay let's get through that
window okay so they're situated mostly
on this side things across the road I'll
probably get shot at from
here but okay fighting around here
somewhere that's one
down took a hit but I think we're doing
way okay
I will say it is nice having so much
room on the screen to really just like
navigate the menus and
stuff it's really quite
[Applause]
helpful let's just heal up real quick
before anyone gets any funny
ideas okay not exactly my best firefight
but you know what we're running we're
still alive you know there will be some
work involved when it comes to
optimizing the way you play games they
are firing me from
somewhere can't exactly pick out where
it is but oh there you are let's just
get into
that holy
ha one down it's kind of my fault that I
kind of ran so far away from the pack
but yeah I'll be able to handle myself I
know I can it's all
good all right
currently about 10 minutes into the game
we are at 58% and I finally found a
vehicle it's a monst the trucked let's
hop in
there very very nice sounds coming up
from the
speakers it's it's nice because at the
same time because the speakers are
playing it out right you have a bit of
hetic feedback if I can call it that
coming in from this so it's nice to hold
and play let's just go pick up blue real
quick
oh he got me good he got me real
good
hit bit too high still a bit of a
problem he's firing us from that one
tree I can just run over him though yeah
let's just do that let's just run over
him oh wait never mind the circle's
going to catch us
okay going to need
to get the guy real
quick
help come
on
help help okay that was stupid of me
okay I'm not the
smartest but with that that concludes
our playr of pubg mobile not my best
game whatever all right so let's just
check them just real quick I am very
embarrassed right now okay so
35° 38 wow okay it just kind of heat me
up a little bit down here 33 35 36 okay
not too bad not what I was expecting
honestly because I did expect it to do
slightly better compared to Call of Duty
mobile because you know we aren't
exactly on like amazing Graphics but you
know you know what it's still below 4 I
don't know why it's a 38 3 5
36 let's check this out 31 32 all right
let's check here 30 30 not the spikes
aren there huge here for some reason I'm
not getting anything like 39ish I come
on yeah it's still about 34 35 around
that chip area 52% battery so that went
now like 4% in our entire playthrough so
not too bad not too bad honestly FPS
hasn't dropped at all so let's just get
into our final thoughts the Oppo Fine
entry more than that the Snapdragon 8
Gen 2 and adreno 740 combo Wombo is one
you can't go wrong with especially
Juiced up with 16 gigs of RAM
surprisingly you handle hry stario
pretty well holding up till about the 35
minute Mark where we saw our first major
frame rate drop in the game besides that
the game did eat into some 208% of
battery from a 43 minute playthrough on
a balanced battery setting so imagine it
on the Pro Gamer setting genin again
isn't well optimized I mean we have the
phone before launch and it's a common
theme but I will say the fine N3 handles
it well enough even in its current state
the unfolded display is pretty sick and
I think I can give genin some credit for
not having Le boxing like honai star and
also how the UI is sort of tail it for
this generation of affordable phones
Call of Duty and pubg ran without a
hitch of course the backbone isn't super
suited for the Oppo fin in 3 unless you
have a cover to level up the camera
module so it's smoother for pubg's case
default fov is pretty far up for me on
this phone at least but besides that it
plays very well once you conf configure
the controls to your gameplay style
you're working with a 20x 9 screen which
wouldn't be the usual for many people
out there so take your time to configure
your controls to get the best experience
out of it except for the horo verse game
since they don't allow it all in all the
Oppo 59 3 is one with a pack of Snap
Dragon h& 2 Pro Plus adrenal s faulty
equipped phones and you honestly can't
go wrong with its surprising thermal
management just get ready to get used to
the camera module sticking out the back
or you know just get a cover would you
be getting the Oppo Fine N3 let me know
in the comment section below and leave
your question there if you have any and
we'll do our best to get to them if you
like what we do make sure to follow us
on all of our socials right here and
maybe leave a like and hit that
subscribe button it goes a long way
anyway this is Zeno have a great week
and I'll catch youall
[Music]
soon
oh